so when he goes over to the Sarge and  says sergeant establish a recon post  downstairs Code Red you know what to do  sergeant says yes sir  he humps off and he goes down by the  bucket of soldiers goes you heard him  Code Red repeat we are at Code Red recon  plan Charlie execute let's move move  move move and all the soldiers start  jumping on the bucket and they start  marching the other toys are watching and  then we cut to the hallway all is quiet  the medic is taking care of the wounded  guy and he gives the thumbs-up he's okay  and we we drift over and we find the  sergeant sort of camouflage and he gets  out of binocular saying look singles  there they are and then we see through  the binoculars you know there's the  presence that's what everyone's interest  it's going to be